There's a difference between
a business making a lot of money,
and actually being profitable.
Right?
>> Absolutely.
We want our start-up to generate
earnings that eclipse its expenses.
If our business generate 1
million a month in revenue,
but need to pay in expenses one and
a half, we are in a problem.
However, if in the same scenario,
our expenses are only half a million,
then we are generating real profits.
>> So,
how do we make our start-up profitable?
>> It's very easy.
You should follow these
three simple steps.
First, build a wonderful,
amazing product, so
good your user can't ignore it.
Second, charge money for it.
Third, boom profits!
>> Oh yes, that sounds so easy.
Let's just end the course right here.
I mean, but just because somebody
puts a price tag on a product doesn't
mean that someone's going to pay it.
>> That's right.
As Warren Buffett used to say, price
is what you pay, value is what you get.
This is why you should focus on
creating real value for your customers.
People will be willing to pay if they
see and recognize the value in it.
You got a bigger chance of building
a profitable business that is
making 2 million a year,
rather than trying to create the next
multi-billion dollar business.
If you think on your
start-up from this angle,
you got a higher probability
to make it happen.